do you guys have any ticks
i i have some fake ones yeah like maybe
yeah my mouth moves a lot when people
are talking because i'm trying to
predict what they're going to say yeah
yeah then people just like yeah his
brain moves fast like they'll give you
credit
sometimes all those twitches work to
your benefits yeah yeah yeah sometimes i
don't know what to say yeah and watching
his mouth will complete the sentence for
me oh really
i
my neurons don't connect as fast as his
yeah yeah so i'll be like how he's like
how are you today i'm like i'm and he'll
go tired with his mouth i'm tired oh and
it's usually very true and honest i'm
like i am tired wow i shadow box a lot
i'll always shadow box when i have
energy yeah yeah and it's just like
people are always like oh hey he's
restless he's got a lot of you know
vitality yeah but i hope that's what
they're saying they might not be saying
those words but are you purposely doing
so people that could have that feeling
i think it's i think part of it is like
i could channel it in another direction
but i like the way it looks so i'm gonna
keep doing it i mean i think i'm sure
with effort i could corral it but i'd
rather do it and uh i'd rather stick out
and be a little weird than just like
holstering everything
yeah right i mean it seems like people
like yeah yeah
yeah i mean i just think what what are
mine
you have to know mine
your ticks yeah when i'm nervous or
accused that i'm like short circuiting
wait what is that have i seen her do
that
you just don't like that when i'm mad
yeah yeah like this yeah i clench yeah i
over blink
so i blink excessively if i'm
uncomfortable yeah if i'm trying i do
that too i blink too much yeah i don't
think you blink enough i'm terrified
yeah
and i don't know what her handle is but
he's lived like a whole life in thailand
she's like a white girl but i am
terrified of her i always scroll past
really quickly because i have not seen
her blink
in like
the two years that she's been a content
creator not once i'm terrified of people
that don't blink because i'm like how do
you do that
like what is how are you just so like i
feel like i equate that to someone being
really like calm and knowing
because i i just short circuit all the
time so my eyes go like this they
flutter
she probably read michael caine's acting
book what what is he's like you don't
blink on camera if you want to be
confident and strong you don't blink on
camera when you look in the camera with
your
closest eye or no you're near your
farthest eye what's the farthest
uh close to the south the camera's right
there on my right-hand side you stare at
it with your left
but he looks
i think that works yeah he looks at the
other actor's eyes with his left eye
right wait so they're on the right i'm
doing a scene with jt right yeah and the
camera's there
yeah right so i look with this eye to
the camera no no no no no
that doesn't work it's powerful whoa
yeah it's working it's working off me
dude yeah
if i'm like too much i'm like here yeah
i don't know yeah yeah here's my rule
with that all right because i'm shooting
a movie right now right yeah so what i
i'm always aware with the camera is so i
just if if i'm not i lock eyes with the
guy yeah if i'm not locking eyes with
the guy i'm looking into the camera you
have a question yeah um since you guys
are experts um what eye do you look at
in a person
what the [ __ ] you talking about when
you're talking to somebody both eyes
both i have two eyes one eye is on the
other you know what i mean
no way
you can't look at both you can look at
both it's impossible
right now where are you i swear to god
i'm looking at both i'm looking at both
too yeah yeah i'm looking
at both eyes right now yeah i'm locked
in i'm locked into i mean i can see the
other eye but i'm locked into your left
what
i